underwear yes it did exactly what you
wanted
camera at the beginning I changed my
underwear today you guys should be so
proud of me oh it's about time I was
like she smells different today
hey reject nation i'm greg alba how are
you this is adorkable rachel I'm doing
fine thank you hi everyone she does
reactions and reviews on her channel as
well right now she is binging the MCU
films because she's prepping to check
out infinity war this week we are
expecting a review from you yes I'm so
excited about it
I already softened you or you can check
out our review on this channel and we
also have a sketch of the beginning we
have a love for you guys to go watch
that while we're here we should check
out cinemasins
everything wrong with thor ragnarok in
15 minutes or less which is always fun
to see the flaws and movies that you
love a lot of people don't like that but
I love it I love it too I look so let's
moving one time but it'll be fun to see
what I agree with him what I disagree
with are ya ready Rachel I am I saw it
once too but I loved it this is the
movie that finally really got me into
Thor so I'm excited a lot of people can
agree with that let's check it out
alright let's do it
41 seconds of logos you know what this
Disney Fox merger goes through there's a
good chance it's going to someone get
the skeleton an agent because it has
tremendous dramatic timing holy Sh
that's clancy brown things just got
about a hundred times more parallax up
in this joint also this is what happens
when you open up your superhero
cinematic universe to aliens gets wonky
and cartoony in a hurry just ask
Steppenwolf who incidentally is also a
giant on fire alien monster I cannot die
not until I fulfill my destiny and lay
waste to your own destiny for him and
everyone else
he's like an intergalactic air be no
roll credits the great prophecies
prophecies also great prophecies will
burn this entire opening scene is
villain monologuing done to the extreme
not that your offhanded and stashing
away NASCAR's fault right next to the
thing this guy wants needs to combine it
with are you crazy
oh yeah that was really not ascertain
real porn website for hammer porn unless
you like smash don't waste the 25
seconds individually smashing enemies if
you can do this
did he just like level up or something
that's a good boy just kill him wouldn't
that probably be an important step in
fulfilling the prophecy the server know
that Thor will make the right decision
to put his horns on the eternal flame
later the Odin charged Hyundai was
negligence to Jimmy by he just bid for
the truck
goddamn scourge do you ever stop dude
there was no point in jogging to the
city to arrive 10 minutes after Thor
were like you've accomplished invest in
intercoms and or radios or shorter
bridges Bob strike back finding
Forrester and entourage I'm thinking
Matt Damon has a shot at the best
collection of cameos award that doesn't
exist do me a favor
well fish away in the vault so it
doesn't turn into a giant monster
destroying the whole planet
the one thing that can fulfill the
prophecy of Surtur changing into mecha
godzilla is kept in the only place where
it can cause harm this is like if you
buried parallax in the pet cemetery also
planet planet at the end of this thing
we will see your entire civilization as
a city floating through space on a
jagged rock it's a comet or an asteroid
way before it's a planet be male and
female actors behind Thor here are
associate faking conversations so
important you would ignore the first
appearance by thorne ears that I'm
wondering if that's true but also Thor
can fly which can't really be this guy's
well damn it if you were worried about
Thor return to Asgard without you
knowing it you should have picked a
better hero it's why in general you can
never take death seriously in these
movies big dramatic death scenes turn
into parody plays starring Matt Damon
don't know I don't have a phone but you
could have sent to the electronic letter
it's called an email well this banter is
pretty funny you've got to think Doctor
Strange has ways of communicating that
don't involve phones or emails Astra
that's just beautiful Wow Norway it
looks fake ish no I've stopped writing
Rach I put it in disorder it's already
begun she's coming
Odin who is thousands of years old plays
the pronoun game so the Thor has to ask
who the hell she is gonna suggest no
sister Odin have a daughter that he's
kept secret all this time and while he
admittedly screwed up by not telling
Thor about her and what she can do this
sounds more like the type of thing where
the character of Odin didn't know about
her either the same thing the crazy
universe we live in when someone can
imprison a person with magic but can't
stop that person with the same magic
move on I'm gonna different paths now
this you must face alone well thanks dad
you created this mess by your own
admission and then you waited until you
were this close to death to even tell us
about it goddamn space Catwoman is hot
yeah
power is drawn from Asgard how is he
able to do this on earth
Odin told us her powers would be
limitless on Asgard so how is this not
already limited this possible why did
decide to channel that this group
started out as Maleficent - and this is
the only thing that survived from the
first Drive the beings will now fly
through a wormhole
that's moody casually kills a couple of
Thor's buddies and it should be a lot
more meaningful to us because of what
they mean the full offer a full of trash
and tell me this isn't the same place
where the transformers found themselves
and the Transformers the move we're
about to hear dare to be stupid during a
fight scene
[Music]
it's kind of crazy how little this movie
has to do with Ragnarok it's like a side
quest that you play in a Thor RPG if you
had the time in last saw hello she was
at the Bifrost gate and it killed two
people
now she's deep into the city surrounded
by a giant army of Asgardians what
exactly transpired where she walked from
one end of the city to the other and
through this kind of an audience without
the army trying to uh yeah a good boy to
see me maybe give them I don't know any
kind of proof that you're actually
Odin's offspring and maybe they'll come
around you just said something now you
seem shocked no one believed you what is
even the point here she defeated and
banished Thor and Loki with ten percent
of the effort she's putting forth here
dispatching the generic Asgardian armor
to have the infrastructure to put
prisoners through a virtual Epcot Center
ride that gives them all it is the
collection point for all lost and
unloved things not true because I see
neither my college Temple of the dog CD
nowhere my college self one of which was
lost and one of which was unloved so the
room every 20 years or so Jeff Goldblum
emerges from his hibernation to feed
mate appear in movies and become a big
deal for three to four years before
going back into the ground in the
Avengers infinity story in space we know
you've been banished for decades but you
finally come home expect a society that
banished you to have taught your story
to impressionable kids stirred somehow
avoids getting his head smashed in by
all that sealing that just crashed down
with the eternal flame you are reborn
that's exactly what this person who has
so much power she can take out an entire
army by herself needs an army also this
eternal flame has a ton of uses doesn't
it it's how certain will become a huge
Colossus when he puts his horns in it
and it can raise an army of the undead
it's one of those weird elements and
movies that do whatever you need it to
do at a moment's now
Oh green glowing army of the Dead and
Cate Blanchett Lord of the Rings
similarity will this movie think of next
[Music]
today underneath the Blade Runner sequel
I think it's gonna read of this place to
be whatever you wanted it to be so why
did he create a world where the glitchy
hologram exists Chris Hemsworth is way
way better looking than me
[Music]
okay haha we all remember what Hulk did
to Loki in the Avengers but he's been
here for weeks
and he's in good standing with the
Grandmaster so how does he not know the
Hulk is here after weeks of being on
this planet he would have at least been
given a description of this guy
right I'm happy to see you you've
definitely know better than to address
Hulk a spanner or to think one can
influence the other all right this is
what we've been waiting for Hulk vs Thor
we haven't seen this ever except in the
first Avengers on the airship and Thor
had his hammer
hope should probably make quick work of
Thor under those circumstances since it
was essentially a draw the first time
look probably not over three minutes of
marginally thrilling no stakes gladiator
fighting between two Avengers basically
space Civil War on a smaller scale so
the war sliders if you will I'm sorry is
this hammer supposed to have the power
those real hammer
Hulk just through Thor were like a
tennis ball a second ago and now with a
random huge hammer Thor is able to bat
Hulk around like Bryce Harper in a
little league game well they finally did
it
they turned Thor into Raiden wouldn't
the ability to shock Thor be impossible
at this point since he's got the power
character other than I'm evil and want
to rule the universe so you need to fill
in the gaps have a gunslinger we say
welcome designer cuts now you arrived
here
we still doesn't answer the question
yeah the Quinn jet can be used to fly in
space but of all the places in the
universe Hulk could have flown that
Quinjet the fact that he just happens to
be on this planet is 2009 JJ Abrams Star
Trek Spock cave level of improbability
where does the Quinjet now showing where
the Quinn jet is will require a naked
halt to simply point out the window
rather than just telling Thor were to
look the sine doll vision is super
convenient did we even know this was
possible that Heimdall could bring
someone to Asgard via vision this
doesn't work The Avengers civil for Jeff
seid on TJ this remote works so that it
would release him from the shop okay the
button his person here is no different
from what about repressed to shock him
earlier and considering how this movie
works I'm surprised he didn't shock
himself for a big laugh Point Break good
thing this ship is still totally
functional after being here on this joke
planet for nearly two years that's not a
big surprise this is not what she said
in age of Ultron and that would be she
said the job was finished and absolutely
nothing about the whereabouts of Ultron
it's almost like this movie needed an
easy reference for which movie this was
from so they invented an alternate
recording just for the seat why does
this old misinformation back to banner
now but didn't do so when she originally
sent it yeah about that
how does banners demeanor stay
sufficiently angry even during sleep to
stay home for two years what does this
mean to just both go and try and do it
Jesus is there any reason only one of
them would get sent after Thor and Hulk
I just don't get Loki at all he has all
these illusions at his fingertips but
instead of using Matt he's like a guy
from death wish trying to wrap Charles
Bronson taps into the mind of Valkyrie
to see the trailer for Valkyrie not to
be confused with the Tom Cruise tries to
kill Hitler movie this is just gorgeous
everything about this scene is rad would
you stop saying stay nice it outloud
somehow comes out of characters mouth at
the same time
[Music]
domination well isn't that the most
convenient appearance ever not only
Valkyrie find a way to go to the exact
place she needed to be at this moment
but the Beast that was about to hit Thor
also had a controlling device on his
neck
it's a driving time more importantly are
those grapes it's kind of amazing that
the Grand Master allowed Bal Cree to
continue to have control over all these
prisoners after she sold them to him why
doesn't he have his own controlling
devices on them once the sale is
complete I'm not doing get help
characters do the thing that they said
they wouldn't do immediately after
saying they wouldn't do it cliche it's
just another spaceship that was easy
no matter was that it was right you can
stand on top of a spaceship that
explodes not getting hurt at all and by
some sort of magic you can get thrown to
another ship and grab it by the seams as
it hurtles through the air how are all
these ships missing doctoring Mario
jumps her way across the bad guy ships
to do some miracles and it's sad it's
cool it's cool anyway okay movie you
can't have it both ways
you can't bring comedy from banner
shouting about how hard should be for
him to fly an alien spaceship then
perfectly for the rest of the movie the
word anus than most important or even
most proctology lectures Rachel one
thank you does she have any reason for
local knowledge he's not any stronger
than the next Asgardian she can execute
people herself quite easily his
character is here so that he can have a
change of heart at the it but I can't
think of a single purpose he serves for
hella other than to stand in water
listen while she does and says
expositional things that we the audience
need to learn
yeah the mountains heat signatures
people clustered together how is it so
easy for this ship to find the people
and thereby the Bifrost sword but the
god of death who flings daggers with her
brain and crushes magic hammers wasn't
able to find it until she threatened to
start beheading fools and someone told
her words wow she really did the eyeball
map on those doors perfectly I'm not
sure I understand forward battle plan
here the last time he ran into hell she
started his hammer into oblivion
he doesn't realize yet that he can
control his power without the hammer so
what's the plan yeah no one wanted to
see what happened next or anything
[Music]
weapon cause that wound but no heritage
damage outside the OP yes
the wolf is immune to bullets because we
need a reason for banner who has been
useless as a character here to turn back
into the whole this is just plain
awesome even though I've Norton did this
in the Incredible Hulk and it wasn't
played for laps I don't think I quite
understand how Bruce dying makes the
Hulk emerge but I think it's consistent
with what these movies are saying is
posture so I'm removing this into this
[Music]
luckily this triggers Thor's Dumbledore
dreams so Odin can give him the message
from beyond the grave or ether wherever
Odin where that Hama mister have you
control your power to focus it there's
nothing a source of strength thanks dad
you could have told me about my power
way before this literal ex machina dream
yeah I realized these revelations need
to arrive in the stupidest way possible
like I know so begins one of the longest
walks ever so that the heroes can figure
out how to fight hella the truth about
Ragnarok and the very meaning of life
before she arrives hella has shown
nothing but completely utterly infinite
power since she first showed up in this
movie there isn't a gauge for how much
more power she can take
[Laughter]
well ticket then you didn't take
cinemasins advice and take Surtur's
crown light-years away from this place
but it's not yes Loki's going to steal
this because Loki's got a Loki my
question is if he had free rein on
Asgard for as long as he did why hasn't
he already stolen this thing and used it
yeah good for you for finally doing the
right thing after all those times you
did the wrong and horrible thing Karl
Urban commando do you really think it's
a good idea to bring me back to earth no
especially since you [ __ ] already
agreed it would be in Loki's best
interest to stay on Sekar and you know
Doctor Strange is going to yeah do you
guys forget everything in order to
service the future plot because space is
apparently a one lane highway Thor's art
runs into Thanos the ship on the way to
earth to infinity war and beyond
you can't have a revolution without
somebody to overthrow so you're welcome
and it's a tie aren't you glad you
waited through ten minutes of credits to
see that holy crap so many revelations
for the future of marvel there yeah I'm
glad I prevented the ushers from
cleaning this movie raggle punishment
yeah that's us that's also excluded we
must be hella
[Music]
what Harry Potter yeah no doing this I
love this movie by the way
[Music]
no I just ass I am
[Music]
not until I fulfill my destiny and lay
waste yes
that's just like Disney World I was just
there yeah Wow cinemasins
put together an epic video again I feel
like most of this was actual just like
insane nitpicks
like every once in a while that's like
of course or cinemasins most of the time
it isn't just nitpicks but every once in
a while you watch a video of there's
really like you know that's a good point
and I found myself mainly going yeah
just a cinema significant stead of
actually agreeing what's them say you
know but there definitely was a few
things we were like oh you're right I
didn't notice that yeah sure but I mean
in these movies especially with
superhero movies it's to be expected
that there's always gonna be like little
plot points here and there of course oh
yeah they could have totally gotten
around that but then again it just comes
down to whether or not that completely
takes you out of being able to enjoy the
movie yeah with those kind of picks for
me not so much no I still really enjoy
watching this movie again regardless ya
bikini when it comes like their action
sequences like in the very beginning
where he has the hammer and then who
they're pointing out how he could have
just done that big giant thing earlier
to see the mole asset of like
individually taking them out yeah sure
that could have happened that way the
same time that I'm like it looks cool
it's cool it's executed it was fun to
watch that's all that matters and I'd
rather to keep it that way sort of
nitpicks I just don't agree with like
Thor returns in its first just running
across the bridge like yeah I know
there's no point in Scourge going but
what dude oh yeah it's an alignment with
this character did you know that the guy
who plays Thor in the play with Matt
Damon is actually one of Chris
Hemsworth's brother the guy who's on yes
I did know that I did not know that
until very very recently it is nowhere
that they took a lot of points back cuz
yes this movie was that awesome
yeah that's sure you know it's a good
movie with cinema since have to take
your points back I agree with the point
of how when hella shows up she kills off
too with those buddies who were so
significant as part of Thor's team in
the first two Thor movies and how that's
kind of just meaningless here awesome
you see hella she just arrives in Asgard
and then next time you see her she's in
front of this huge crowd of people and
soldiers and stuff and it is that
question of how did all these people
just assemble here now and she has this
giant arena for July for people to watch
her movie magic
yeah yeah yeah like whatever and then
but that is a good point in terms of she
does start individually fighting every
soldier when she kind of takes out the
worst hammer like it's nothing there's
no point to her really fighting but
that's just another thing of but it
looks cool it's a cool fight the bigger
flaws in movies to me are the ones that
you notice upon first viewing but you
don't really think about that kind of
stuff when you first see it it just kind
of makes sense upon viewing it yeah like
you said it's just fun to watch and I
think that this movie is filled with so
much of that it's like who cares that
there's flaws it's just a really fun
that's the whole point of the movie is
it's just it's nothing but fun yeah
there's other flaws too of how Loki just
discovers the Hulk being there but
Loki's been there for a few weeks and he
would have had at least have heard
because they call him the Hulk here and
he would have heard one time about who
this crazy gladiator is since all of our
Popular's have all Sekar thrives off
these gladiator matches yeah he would
have heard of him at one time I did
always wonder that about that though
like how did he stay Hulk
during the few weeks that he was here
even when he's sleeping yeah because I
think I remember even thinking like did
I miss something that they like
interject him with something that makes
dainty all that we're forgetting about
yeah and they didn't seem like to have
any idea who Bruce Banner was yeah or
their that is one I think flaw that they
could have managed to fix in this movie
because they're implying that he got to
just shows up as Hulk
yeah it just stays that way the whole
time so yeah that is that that is a
pretty big just one of those things like
hey all I needed was one sentence of
explanation one sentence okay with this
really wrapped it up I mean most of this
I've just fine to be incredibly detailed
nitpicks that I'm like sure he could
ding them whatever overall still a fun
video yeah it's a lot of fun cinemasins
is usually just fun to me yeah I usually
watch them ago yeah absolutely
good job to you cinemasins thanks for
watching with us you guys can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification bell more importantly
follow adorkable Rachel on YouTube
we follow her she does reactions and
reviews over there as well so please do
us a solid follow her or else she'll
never come back on this channel which
will make this guy sad
you too bye thank you